So we learned a lot about regression.
In all the examples we saw so far, there was exactly one input variable.
For example, we learned a function that predicted the net worth based on age.
One input, one output.
Now, there's a form of regression where it can have many different input
variables, IQ, your age and maybe your education.
And those jointly can predict the net worth of a person.
There's a name for this.
This is called multi-variate regression.
It's not an intuitive name, but that's what it's called.
So let me give you an example in which the net worth is the function of
two variables, x1 equals age, and x2 is the IQ.
And we have certain age levels, 20, 40, and 60 here, and
certain IQ levels, say, 80, 100, and 120.
And in this example,
I'm going to fill out all the nine combinations of these input variables.
In this example, I'm going to give you nine data points corresponding to
the nine combinations of these numbers over here.
And your task is it, by hand, by sheer thinking,
to figure out the formula that explains this data.
So we have y, and y is the net worth, is some
number that you will tell me times x1, which is the age, plus some other number,
times x2, which is the IQ, plus potentially a third number.
It's a challenging question, but
can you figure out what numbers to put in here, here, and here?
And as a hint, work horizontally first, then work vertically, and
the other numbers should just fall into place.